un groupe aux morts je ne pense pas mais
un groupe de la majorité présidentielle
je le pense
aujourd'hui il ya dérobé ya des
marchands dans tous les groupes et les
marcheurs brooks et sioniste jonah au
rdse et il y en a chez les malgaches les
centristes quelques-uns
le propeller donc l'étude voir
aujourd'hui de penser pouvoir dans le
contexte que nous connaissons avant les
statines
créer un groupe comptait mener ce que
nous est proposé hier ce que nous avons
composé c'est de nous parler de voir
comment dans l'avenir sans doute après
la rentrée
après les élections de septembre si
elles ont lieu en septembre leur étant
organisé la rentrée parlementaire pour
avoir une expression commune une unité
commune dans le social nous allons
apporter au gouvernement donc il s'agit
pas aujourd'hui
or de faire des mini groupe uni groupe
qui serait qu'ils seraient pas
suffisamment à la fois représentatif
politiquement intelligent et intelligent
il s'agit de parler entre nous savoir
comment nous pouvons organiser une
parole de soutien au public
ensemble tout en respectant les
différences donc vous êtes un
intergroupe s'est pas non mais attends
on peut avait été évoquée mais quelques
temps pour l'instant nous ne sommes pas
vraiment sur cette formule il n'a pas
défini l'enfant ne voulais pas qu il
cherchait une maison commune